schönen guten abend dann euch herzlich
willkommen zu zdf heute live ich freue
mich sehr dass ihr wieder mit bei uns im
stream sein bei uns geht es heute wohl
um den größten steuerskandal den
deutschland je erlebt hat es geht um den
sogenannten comex skandal so viele
offene punkte so viele ungereimtheiten
und sicher natürlich auch fragen von
euch deswegen gerne her damit entweder
per mail zdf
heute.de zdf.de oder ihr stellt das in
die app oder einfach direkt in den chat
wir versuchen natürlich so viele wie
möglich zu beantworten
natürlich auch rund um die rolle von ihm
hiervon bundeskanzler olaf scholz zum
zweiten mal ging es heute für ihn vor
den hamburger untersuchungsausschuss die
entscheidende frage wie schon vor einem
jahr hat scholz im jahr 2016 damals als
erster oberbürgermeister in hamburg
einfluss genommen im comic skandal auf
drohende steuerrückzahlungen der
warburg-bank das ordnen wir einen
darüber sprechen wir gleich mit chakuza
banerjee sie war für uns heute in
hamburg vor ort hat scholz und natürlich
auch den untersuchungsausschuss verfolgt
schönen guten abend nach hamburg
unterlagen des dubai ist
keine guten an
wir sprechen im weiteren verlauf des
streams auch mit valerie haller zdf
finanzexperten um so ein bisschen die
generellen fragen rund um den comic
skandal für euch zu erörtern bleiben wir
aber erstmal bei scholz bisher hat der
ja immer gesagt ich habe nichts gemacht
und so wirklich erinnern kann ich mich
auch nicht an damals über dreieinhalb
stunden wurde scholz heute vor dem
u-ausschuss in hamburg befragt und das
ist ein statement nach heute ich freue
mich sehr dass ich hier in hamburg sein
kann das war für mich auch etwas
besonderes in der
bürgerschaft zu setzen auch auf dem
platz den ich als bürgermeister lange
eingenommen habe das war heute eine sehr
interessante anhörung eine gute auch mit
wie ich jedenfalls finde sehr klaren
ergebnissen es bleibt dabei es hat keine
politische einflussnahme auf die
entscheidung der finanzbehörden die
finanzverwaltung gegeben sind keine
tatsachen bekannt geworden die gegen
diese klare aussage sprechen und deshalb
war es gut dass das heute in einer sehr
kurzen sitzung auch noch mal vertieft
erörtert werden konnte gebe zu ich hatte
mich darauf eingerichtet dass es viel
länger dauert aber die tatsache dass ist
dann schnell und zügig war spricht
vielleicht auch für die tatsache dass
alles nun mittlerweile auf dem tisch
liegt und man auch die klare
schlussfolgerung ziehen kann da war
nichts es hat keine einflussnahme
gegeben schon dank
also bundeskanzler olaf scholz bleibt
seiner bisherigen linie treu er betont
sich irgendwie betont munter und sagt es
gibt nichts und erinnern kann ich mich
auch nicht tag und lass uns das mal
einordnen wie hast du den auftritt von
scholz heute erlebt und wie bewertest du
auch dieses statement klingt ja fast
nach einem freizeit besucht dafür den
bundeskanzler
ja das sieht man das gibt eigentlich
ganz gut die laune wieder in der wir
ihnen heute hier erlebt haben ich fand
es schon ein bisschen überraschend nach
dieser sitzung dass er hier sogar mit
einem lächeln direkt vor die kamera
gegangen ist aber das zeigt eben dass
die ganze befragung wahrscheinlich in
etwa so gelaufen ist wie er sich das
vorgestellt hatte er ist gleich zu
beginn als er als er reingekommen ist
und sich dann auf seinen alten
bürgermeisterstuhl gesetzt hat das war
der platz auf dem er hier heute befragt
wurde relativ locker gewesen hat sich
erst mal bedankt aufführen hat gesagt
ich freue mich dass ich hier bin und
dass wir noch mal die gelegenheit haben
miteinander zu reden und hat dann noch
mal 20 minuten erklärung drangehängt in
der er praktisch seine sicht der dinge
noch einmal sehr betont hat nämlich
dieses berühmte das war nichts was wir
jetzt heute schon gehört haben und
gerade eben im abschluss statement dann
auch noch mal gehört haben und er hat
viele viele medienberichte zitiert die
für ihn sprechen aus seiner sicht die
ihn entlassen die indizien dafür liefern
dass er eben keinen einfluss genommen
hat und er hat das ganze auch noch
einmal verbunden mit einer art
selbstdarstellung er hat gesagt
steuerhinterziehung lädt er natürlich ab
jegliche form von steuerhinterziehung
und steuerbetrug ist eine straftat und
er habe sein ganzes politisches leben
damit verbracht sich für ein gerechtes
steuersystem
einzusetzen also der ganze eindruck den
er vorne da machen wollte war eben
offensichtlich zu sagen ich bin
überzeugt davon dass ich nichts falsches
gemacht habe und meine politischen taten
sprechen ja auch für sich deswegen
sollte man mir so etwas nicht
unterstellen dass schwang damit und das
zog sich durch die ganze sitzung durch
ist er so hart bei seiner linie
geblieben und hat immer wieder betont
ich habe keinen politischen einfluss
genommen ich konnte ja bei uns im chat
tauchen schon auch ganz viele
irritierende worte so über diese
gelassenheit auf du hast auch gesagt
dass dich das verwundert weil die
vorwürfe oder auch die rolle von scholz
und die vorwürfe rund um comics und
diesen steuerskandal die könnten
natürlich auch schwerer zu tragen kommen
vielleicht machen wir es noch mal
konkret was würde oder was wird olaf
scholz dann im zusammenhang mit dem
hamburger comics komplex vorgeworfen
ja das ist eigentlich eine gute frage
denn die frage ist ja wie hart kann man
die vorwürfe machen wir hatten hier
mitten in dieser sitzung ein statement
des obmanns der linken der gesagt hat
uns fehlen eigentlich die belege was wir
was wir wollen ist herauszufinden was in
den treffen gelaufen ist die urlaubs mit
den spitzenvertretern der warburg-bank
hatte ob eben in diesen treffen in
irgendeiner form versprechen gemacht
oder angedeutet wurden und ob sich
daraus vielleicht daneben einflussnahme
ergeben hätte denn so der verdacht und
der vorwurf man habe ja gesehen es gab
treffen und in einer nicht allzu langen
zeit danach gab es auch resultate im
sinne der warburg-bank dass es der
vorwurf der im raum steht der lässt sich
nur eben auch nach aussage dieses
genannten ausschussmitglieder es nicht
hart belegen und dann bleibt eben nur
die möglichkeit zu versuchen in einer
befragung olaf scholz in widersprüche zu
verwickeln
oder noch einmal aufzuzeigen dass er
immer an bestimmten stellen
erinnerungslücken zeigt wo es für ihn
vielleicht unangenehm wird und damit
seine glaubwürdigkeit anzukratzen
ja du hast für uns den ganzen tag über
diesen untersuchungsausschuss verfolgt
es geht oder die fragen richteten sich
natürlich an seine zeit als erster
oberbürgermeister der stadt hamburg was
haben dann nochmal für fragen auf den
tisch und wie hat scholz da agiert in
dem untersuchungsausschuss
es ging natürlich noch einmal um die
frage wen hat er wann getroffen und
worüber wurde gesprochen da hat scholz
genau das gemacht was er auch in der
sommerpressekonferenz vor einigen tagen
in berlin schon angekündigt hat nämlich
noch einmal zu wiederholen was er hier
bei seiner ersten befragung vor diesem
ausschuss schon einmal gesagt hat das
war relativ wenig und auch da wo er sagt
er kann sich nicht erinnern dabei zu
bleiben genau so ist es heute gekommen
er hat über 30 fragen gestellt bekommen
wurde am ende resümiert und sehr sehr
oft geantwortet mit daran kann ich mich
nicht erinnern dazu liegt man keine
aktive erinnerung vor das weiß ich nicht
also da ist relativ viel offen geblieben
es kamen auch einige neuere fragen auf
den tisch da wurde es dann aber zum teil
sehr kompliziert wir haben in den
letzten tagen hier medienberichte
gesehen die sich bezogen auf
ermittlungen der staatsanwaltschaft köln
die wiederum bezogen sich auf ein
protokoll einer aussage von olaf scholz
im bundestagsfinanzausschuss
dieses protokoll ist als vertraulich
eingestuft worden das kann von
bundestagsabgeordneten nur im bundestag
eingesehen werden ist darf daraus nicht
vorgelesen werden es darf nicht daraus
abgeschrieben werden wir hatten hier
mehrmals die situation dass jemand sagte
ich würde ja daraus gerne zitieren und
sie damit konfrontieren ich kann es aber
nicht ich darf es nicht wir dürfen das
hier in diesem ausschuss nicht tun und
olaf scholz hat das an einer stelle
sogar genutzt und hat gesagt na ja wenn
sie mir die formulierung vorliegen
könnten dann könnte ich was dazu sagen
das konnte dann aber das
ausschussmitglied natürlich nicht tun
wichtiger punkt den du ansprichst gehen
wir gleich auch noch mal drauf rein ich
leite dir ganz kurz eine user frage von
petric die weiter bei youtube die geht
noch so ein bisschen in dieses
rhetorische stilmittel von scholz warum
spricht er das fragt petrowsky so als
hätte er heute quasi schon recht
bekommen lässt aber die möglichkeit
offen dass dem nicht so wäre hast du
deine erklärung für
weil es ja tatsächlich für ihn aus
seiner sicht um die frage geht ist ihm
etwas ist ihm einen verstoß vorzuwerfen
und den müsste man auch belegen können
wenn man ihm einen vorwurf macht braucht
man einen beweis jetzt sind wir aber in
dem bereich der politischen
einflussnahme dass es heute hier auch
thematisiert wurden es kamen mehrere
fragen wo es hieß herr scholz gestehen
sie denn zu dass politische
einflussnahme nicht unbedingt über eine
zum beispiel schriftliche anweisung
erfolgen kann sondern vielleicht schon
durch ein bestimmtes verhalten durch ein
bestimmtes handeln dass sie als erster
bürgermeister also die möglichkeit
gehabt hätten durch gezieltes nachfragen
oder das signalisieren einer bestimmten
haltung
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter der
finanzbehörde zu einem bestimmten
handeln zu bringen also wir bewegen uns
hier in einem graubereich
es gibt keinen ganz konkreten vorwurf
mit dem heute hier konfrontiert wurde
also dass jemand sagte ich habe hier den
beleg dafür dass sie dem chef der
warburg-bank zum beispiel etwas
bestimmtes versprochen haben sondern es
gibt eben nur diese vermutungen und man
wollte scholz heute dazu bewegen noch
einmal persönlich aus seiner erinnerung
über die treffen zu berichten und das
hat eben nicht geklappt also ich nehme
an dass er an vielen stellen auch so
vage bleibt weil es eben in der
juristischen aufarbeitung nicht genug
gibt um ihn festzunageln und bei der
politischen frage ist es eben relativ
schwierig
ja du beschreibst ganz gutes
spannungsfeld was sich da eben auftut
ein graubereich wir bekommen auch von
berlin dem user bei youtube eine frage
rein gibt es denn aber auch andere
statements als die von olaf scholz und
zwar seitens der vielleicht
koalitionspartner oder eben auch der
opposition und ja die gibt es von den
opel ländern die auch heute in dem
untersuchungsausschuss da waren von der
cdu war dass götz wiese und von der
linken partei zum beispiel norbert
hackbusch und die da schauen wir jetzt
rein gemeinsam die waren richtig sauer
wegen des auftritts des kanzlers er
hatte wieder änderungs lücke nach
erinnerungslücke nach erinnerungslücke
auf den fragenkatalog der vorbereitet
war hat er die ersten fragen praktisch
durchgängig mit erinnerungslücken
beantwortet und das ist tief
enttäuschend heute hat olaf scholz nicht
zur aufklärung in diesem fall
beigetragen für uns ist es auch
unglaubwürdig weil er gleichzeitig sie
natürlich ein bisschen andere sachen
viel besser mal erinnern können und noch
einmal der fakt eine bank tritt auf und
sagt 1500 arbeitsplätze werden die
finanzverwaltung sich durchsetzt sind in
dieser stadt gefährdet und der
bundeskanzler kann sich nicht daran
erinnern das finde ich eine
erschreckende situation
chuck und sarah die statements haben wir
gehört sehr aufgebracht sehr verärgert
wie war dein eindruck da von den männern
heute
genauso das zog sich durch die gesamte
sitzung durch und da ja olaf scholz
nichts anderes gesagt hat als das was er
angekündigt hatte sind die natürlich
auch alle so auseinander gegangen also
scholz in der überzeugung dass er hier
überzeugend darstellen konnte wie wenig
er sich hat zuschulden kommen lassen und
die anderen in der überzeugung dass das
eben alles überhaupt nicht glaubwürdig
ist wir haben übrigens ja gerade gehört
den hinweis darauf dass es heißt scholz
hat sich schon mal besser erinnert das
war dieses besagte protokoll was ich
eben erwähnt habe das streng vertraulich
ist da soll er eben schon mal mehr
details ausgeplaudert haben aus einem
treffen zumindest hat er sich da an
themen erinnert bei denen er vorher
schon mal gesagt hat und da kann ich
mich überhaupt nicht mehr erinnern das
ist etwas wo hier viele fragen heute
drumherum kreisten um die frage wenn sie
sich dadurch schon einmal besser
erinnert haben dann müsste ihnen noch
jetzt vielleicht auch das ein oder
andere einfallen das gipfelte dann in
einer frage aus der cdu wo jemand sagte
herr scholz wären sie denn bereit sich
vielleicht mit dem mittel der hypnose da
nochmal ihren erinnerungen zu nähern
also das war schon eine ein absurder
moment hier wo man gesehen hat die
beiden seiten arbeiten sich auch
aneinander ab und kommen überhaupt nicht
voran man muss auch noch eine sache dazu
sagen es liegt ja auch immer im
ausschuss wie gut vorbereitet ist wie
hart die fragen sind man hat heute den
eindruck es gab nicht viel handfestes
neues womit der ausschuss olaf scholz
hätte konfrontieren können deswegen
konnte er eben auch bei seiner strategie
bzw bei seiner haltung bleiben auch ein
weiterer punkt war ja so hat man
zumindest gehört dass die fragen vorher
auch abgestimmt sein sollen wie
bewertest du denn generell so einen
untersuchungsausschuss wo ja auch leute
aus seiner eigenen partei der spd sind
bei dieser aufklärungsarbeit wie ist da
dieser untersuchungsausschuss zu
bewerten
wer so ein untersuchungsausschuss ist
natürlich auch immer politisch hier
sitzen die die parteien der hamburger
bürgerschaft hier sind auch die spd von
der hat natürlich scholz auch viel
rückendeckung bekommen da gab es ein
mitglied des ausschusses dass immer
wieder wiederholt hat wir haben die
meisten fragen die wir heute stellen
schon einmal gestellt wir haben sie auch
schon mal vom bundeskanzler beantwortet
bekommen und es gibt überhaupt keinen
sinn hier heute nochmal genau dieselben
fragen zu stellen und in der
zwischenzeit hätten über 50 zeugen
ausgesagt und hätten hätten allesamt
miteinander gesagt sie hätten sich nicht
beeinflussen beeinflusst gefühlt also da
merkt man auch dass es hier eine
lagerbildung gibt die spd hat natürlich
ganz klar ihrem bundeskanzler den rücken
gestärkt vor allem cdu und linke haben
besonders scharfe fragen gestellt und
die haben ja jetzt auch schon
angekündigt das was heute hier kam das
reicht ihnen nicht sie möchten gerne
noch einmal eine dritte vorladung für
urlaubs
aussprechen und dann vielleicht auch den
leiter seines kanzleramt es einen engen
vertrauten wolfgang schmidt in engen
vertrauten von olaf scholz hiermit
vorladen also die deuten jetzt schon an
obwohl sie die fragen schon oft
wiederholt haben ist das heute
wahrscheinlich nicht das letzte kapitel
gewesen ja also ein deutlicher
widerspruch zu den aussagen von olaf
scholz der ja gesagt hat dann könnte das
doch an der stelle auch eigentlich
lassen da es weiter bewegung drin bevor
wir vielleicht auch weiter noch über den
ausblick sprechen geben wir euch liebe
userinnen und user man überblick falls
euch jetzt fragte was genau war denn
jetzt nochmal comex generell was was
spielte alles rein keine sorge da hat
christian von rechenberg den durchblick
für uns und zeigt uns das noch mal was
das genau war
compex geschäfte des wie pingpong
schauen in dieser geschwindigkeit kommst
du nicht mehr mit so was klappt doch bei
wertpapieren wenn man sie elektronisch
handelt schnell und raffiniert hin und
her schiebt bis einer den überblick
verliert vater staat und das ist ja das
gewünschte ziel bei compex investor hat
aktien eines unternehmens
dem geht es gut es schüttelt gewinne aus
die dividende auf die moussa
kapitalertragssteuer zahlen die er sich
später aber zurück holen darf nun der
trick das aktienpaket wird rund um den
dividenden tag so lange rasch
weiterverkauft bis man es nicht mehr
verfolgen kann jetzt können andere
beteiligte dem start vorgaukeln auch sie
besitzen diese aktien um sich dann
kapitalertragsteuer zurückzuholen die
sie nie gezahlt haben
ist nicht nur schick und männer die vom
zdf hauptstadtstudio stellvertretende
leiterin ist sie da sondern auch valerie
haller zdf finanzexperten für uns vor
ort an der frankfurter börse schönen
guten abend auch endlich liebe valerie
so wir haben jetzt gerade schon ein
erklärstück zum comic skandal gehört
aber valerie vielleicht bringst du uns
auch noch mal auf den stand wie konnte
das alles überhaupt so passieren was war
da die lücke im system also
interessanterweise ist deutschland ja
vermutlich das geburtsland dieser
finanzgeschäfte hier ging alles los
später dann ging das europaweit und das
war so massiv dass dies einer der
größten steuer betrugsfälle europas
geworden ist das genaue ausmaß das lässt
sich tatsächlich immer noch sehr schwer
erfassen der schaden wird aber auf
mindestens zehn milliarden euro
geschätzt eins ist jedenfalls klar groß
investoren und banken haben mit
steuergeldern kräftig rendite gemacht
geld das an anderer stelle nun fehlt für
kitas schulen die infrastruktur
beispielsweise ja und wie konnte das
passieren weil es ein ganz schön
geschicktes spiel war dass die da
getrieben haben ja so eine art
hütchenspieler trick spiel das haben wir
auch im beitrag gesehen du hast gerade
schon angesprochen schaden von zehn
milliarden euro vielleicht noch mal die
frage auch endlich wie groß ist dieses
ganze ausmaß wie kann man das bemessen
also im grunde genommen müssen wir da
wirklich noch einiges abwarten da laufen
ja auch einige verfahren noch und
insofern wissen wir das noch nicht so
genau es gibt ja neben comics auch noch
diese comcom verfahren und alles in
allem wird das dann noch wesentlich
höher geschätzt auf etwa 30 milliarden
oder sogar noch mehr als das also
wie wir das dann bemessen und wie viel
dann unterm strich dabei rauskommt an
schaden das werden wir dann noch sehen
war wie ein user fragt etwa bei youtube
warum heißt comex comics und nicht
einfach steuerhinterziehung weil es ganz
viele formen von steuerhinterziehung
gibt und comics ich möchte gar nicht so
sehr ins detail eingehen einsteigen weil
das dann doch relativ kompliziert wird
aber es geht auf alle fälle um
dividenden geschäfte und aktien mit
dividende und ohne dividende und darauf
wurde ja eine kapitalsteuer eine
kapitalsteuer bezahlt die dann
zurückgezahlt werden musste und im fall
von comex war es dann eben so dass
derjenige der die kapitalsteuer
rechtmäßig zurück bekommen sollte hat
sie zurückbekommen aber viele andere
eben auch weil die steuerbehörden sich
eben nicht mehr sicher waren wem die
aktien jetzt eigentlich gehört hat im
prinzip ist es ein bisschen so als würde
man für eine pfandflasche nur einmal
pfand bezahlt den kupon kopieren und
dann mehrfach das pfand für diese eine
flasche kassieren danke für deine
erklärung bei einem unglaublichen
steuerskandal unterlage hast zwei mal
auch schon den knackpunkt in der rolle
von olaf scholz angesprochen darüber
reden wir und zwar ein geheimes
protokoll aus einem finanzausschuss im
bundestag und da taucht etwa der uns
gerade die frage weiter geleitet hat
auch noch mal eine frage an dich weil es
ist ja schon ein widerspruch dass da
offenbar doch konkrete erinnerungen von
scholz da gewesen sein sollen im
vergleich wie er sich zum beispiel heute
präsentiert und auch die ganze zeit
davor und die frage des users ist
vielleicht weißt du da was gibt es noch
eine juristische möglichkeit dieses
geheime protokoll irgendwann doch noch
zu veröffentlichen oder wieso darf so
etwas überhaupt geheim gehalten denn das
ist eine frage
also es gibt tatsächlich umstände unter
denen protokolle als geheim eingestuft
werden können eine möglichkeit ist das
steuergeheimnis aber soweit ich das
jetzt verstanden habe spielt das eine
große rolle aber ich gebe zu dass es
eine frage gewesen die ich mir heute
noch mal notiert habe darauf zu schauen
welche möglichkeiten es gibt denn olaf
scholz hat hier in dieser sitzung etwas
gesagt was vorher an anderer stelle mal
anders berichtet wurde er hat gesagt das
bundesfinanzministerium dem wir ja
nochmal dem her bevor bundeskanzler
wurde vorgestanden hat er hätte auf
jeden fall nicht die geheimhaltung
dieses protokoll es veranlasst da war
vorher ein anderer eindruck entstanden
also müssen wir jetzt noch mal genau
schauen wer hat denn eigentlich dafür
gesorgt und warum das dieses dieses
protokoll nicht einzusehen ist es gab
auch schon den versuch wenigstens teile
des protokolls einzusehen haben medien
berichtet und indem man gesagt hat naja
dann schmerzt doch bitte die stellen an
denen es eben besondere geheimnisse gibt
die nicht in die öffentlichkeit gelangen
dürfen und dann kamen das ganze wohl so
stark geschwärzt raus dass man damit
auch nicht mehr viel anfangen konnte
eine frage oder auch eine stimmung die
ich hier bei uns im chat sehr wahrnehme
ist eben die frage was würde das für ein
bild oder ein bild oder ein licht auch
auf den kanzler werfen wenn eben doch
raus kommen sollte dass diese strategie
für die er sich jetzt entschieden hat
das öffentliche erinnerungslücken ich
weiß es nicht wenn sich das am ende dann
doch anders herausstellen sollte und da
fragt uns christoph kutschke per mail
meine frage ist welche auswirkungen
wären dann auf die regierung zu erwarten
falls es doch die politische einwirkung
gab
also wenn sich herausstellen sollte dass
scholz hier den ausschuss belogen hätte
dann hätte das sicherlich gravierende
politische folgen dann müsste er
zurücktreten würde ich sagen und er
hätte sogar strafrechtliche folgen zu
erwarten denn wer hier vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss falsch aussagt
das wurde zu beginn des ausschusses noch
einmal betont der kann dafür bestraft
werden mit bis zu 3 mit drei bis fünf
monaten haft entschuldigung das müsste
ich noch mal nachschlagen ist es gibt
auf jeden fall eine haftstrafe die
darauf stehen also das ist schon eine
ernste angelegenheit sowohl juristisch
als auch politisch aber es würde mit
sicherheit wenn rauskommen würde
belegbar wäre dass er gelogen hat das
ende seiner politischen karriere
bedeuten aber selbst wenn das nicht
belegt wird ist es politisch nicht ganz
ungefährlich für den bundeskanzler das
hat man heute auch gemerkt denn es
kratzt eben an seiner glaubwürdigkeit er
hat ja immer so dieses image gehabt er
ist ein bisschen langweilig und dröge
aber dafür ist er integer und er ist ist
er ist immer korrekt so hat er sich
immer dargestellt und er ist eben ein
kämpfer für steuergerechtigkeit für
gerechtigkeit das ist sein image von
sich selbst und wenn das jetzt
angekratzt wird dadurch dass immer
wieder nachgefragt wird und dass immer
wieder gesagt wird das ist doch nicht
glaubwürdig das kann doch nicht sein
dass sie sich nicht ein gespräch
erinnern bei denen es um 1500
arbeitsplätze in hamburg geht über gegen
bei denen es um eine der
traditionsreichsten banken von hamburg
in wenn das immer wieder aufkommt dann
bleibt irgendwann etwas hängen das hat
er heute auch hier gesagt er sagte
allein die art und weise der befragung
hier die sorgt ja dafür dass der
eindruck entsteht da könnte etwas
gewesen sein das macht ihm sorgen und
das macht ihn zu recht sorgen
danke für deine einordnung vielleicht
noch ganz kurz nachgeschoben von mir
realistisch hältst du das dass es
sozusagen so kippen könnte oder ist dass
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt einfach zu
unseriösen darüber zu sprechen
also es kann keiner in die glaskugel
gucken ich weiß auch nicht wer
vielleicht irgendwo noch mögliche belege
in der hand hat es laufen noch
ermittlungen und es ist ja haffter
anderen seite so dass dieser fall schon
seit jahren unter beobachtung steht das
auch ausschussmitglieder seit jahren
sehr genau darauf schauen also man fragt
sich schon woher kommt dann am ende der
beleg aber ausgeschlossen ist es
selbstverständlich nicht deswegen ist es
wahrscheinlich auch so dass olaf scholz
jetzt immer wieder betont als mensch
würde er sich sehr wünschen dass die
sache mal auf sich dass man die sache
mal auf sich beruhen lässt und jetzt
auch sagt wir haben bisher nichts
gefunden da wird auch nichts mehr sein
aber ich glaube mit dem wunsch wetter
nicht weit kommen
weil er wie auch noch mal eine frage an
dich die auch aus dem bett kommt von
matteo 2007 ist so ein bisschen eine
persönliche frage er sagt wenn ich
persönlich jetzt steuerhinterziehung
betreiben würde wird war nicht zu
empfehlen dürfte ich mich dann auch auf
das steuergeheimnis berufen oh gott ich
bin kein steuerexperte deswegen kann ich
die frage echt nicht so richtig
beantworten aber es ist so dass im comic
skandal zumindest das vielleicht zur
beruhigung zahlreiche strafverfahren vor
deutschen gerichten anhängig sind also
da wird etwas getan dagegen wird
gerichtlich vorgegangen allein bei der
staatsanwaltschaft köln die für viele
viele fälle zuständig ist sollen
inzwischen mehr als 100 fall komplexe
liegen mit über 1400 beschuldigten also
auch die können sich auf das
steuergeheimnis nicht so ohne weiteres
berufen da halten wir fest
steuerhinterziehung am besten einfach
lassen weil wir bleiben trotzdem bei dir
dieser comic skandal wir haben es
thematisiert es ist ein so großer wohl
der größte den deutschland je gesehen
hat was muss sich deiner meinung nach
ändern oder was gibt's vielleicht auch
schon für diskussion und maßnahmen dass
so etwas in zukunft einfach verhindert
werden kann tatsächlich muss man sagen
dass jahrelang nicht viel passiert ist
deswegen konnte das ja auch jahrelang
gut gehen inzwischen sind comics
geschäfte immerhin verboten auch das hat
einige zeit gebraucht sie sind illegal
das ist steuerhinterziehung und die ist
strafbar gehen sie noch immer weiter
diese comics geschäfte da gehen die
meinungen 10 auseinander aber ja
vermutlich gehen sie weiter zumindest in
verschiedensten varianten oder
mischformen das problem ist die steuer
akrobaten sind dem fiskus immer einen
schritt voraus und die steuerbehörden
sind meist unterbesetzt und so ist es
natürlich schwierig steuerkriminalität
zu verhindern die umfassendsten fällen
sollten inzwischen aufgegriffen sein
also eine stärkere besetzung bei den
steuerbehörden das wäre schon immens
hilfreich
ein kleiner ausblick von stark unter
vielleicht war es auch schon
angesprochen jetzt wie sie hat auch
thematisiert dass jetzt die
ausweitung vorangetrieben werden sollen
vielleicht auch auf weitere banken in
hamburg die hsh nordbank wird er zum
beispiel immer wieder genannt wie wird
es deiner meinung nach jetzt in der
nächsten zeit rund um comics und rundum
scholz ja weitergehen
also ich habe hier gerade eben mal ein
paar ausschussmitglieder die
rausgegangen sind weil sie jetzt
feierabend haben gefragt wann wir uns
denn hier wiedersehen mit urlaubs oyster
haben sie gesagt ein termin steht noch
nicht aber so offensichtlich schon so
dass man da ganz ernsthaft darüber
nachdenkt ihn hier noch einmal
vorzuladen es ist ja wie gesagt auch
immer eine politische frage das muss man
dazu sagen ein solcher ausschuss bietet
die möglichkeit den bundeskanzler
kritisch zu befragen und auch die
möglichkeit für die opposition dass da
etwas hängen bleibt natürlich ist das
aufklärungsinteresse steht im
vordergrund das ist auch wichtig und es
wäre auch gut wenn tatsächlich am ende
mal ein glattes ergebnis darunter stehen
würde aber so wie es jetzt aussieht ist
das erst einmal nicht zu erwarten da
wird es auf weitere recherchen der
straff ermittlungsbehörden ankommen da
wird es vielleicht auch auf recherchen
der medien an kommen aber ich bin mir
sehr sicher dann werden viele
journalisten und ermittler dran bleiben
an diesem thema urlaub scholz wird es
nicht so schnell los werden das problem
sagt gunter sauer wenn er die
stellvertretende leiterin unseres
zdf-hauptstadtstudios vielen dank dass
du uns den ganzen tag über den
untersuchungsausschuss auf dem laufenden
hält und hier auch bei uns bei zdf heute
live und ihr später auch einen schönen
feierabend vielen dank
danke natürlich auch an valerie haller
die uns das noch mal so ein bisschen
eingeordnet hat was vakuum ex und wie
kann das in zukunft auch einfach
minimiert werden und auch verhindert
werden vielen dank für deine
einschätzung und seine zeit an der
frankfurter börse hätte gerne
ich bedanke mich natürlich auch sehr bei
euch fürs zuschauen für eure fragen für
eure meinungen die ihre rhein geschickt
bekommen haben was halten wir fest es
gibt keine wirklich neue erkenntnis im
comic skandal und um die rolle von olaf
scholz es ist auch keine neue strategie
da vom kanzler heute vorgetragen worden
zur transparenz das war die kritik an
ihm habe er dadurch auch nicht
beigetragen aber was wir auch gehört
haben ist dass es da noch weitergehen
wird sicherlich auch weitere befragungen
vielleicht geben wird wir haben das im
blick wir werden darüber weiter
berichten auch hierbei zdf heute live
und dann würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn
wir beim nächsten mal auch wieder mit
bei uns am start sein